hey 42 here everyone knows how
successful titanic was we've all seen it
romeo and juliet on the world's most
famous sinking ship
but do you know how close the movie came
to not getting made
titanic was the most expensive movie
ever produced at the time
so expensive in fact that two movie
studios fox and paramount
had to team up to attempt to finance it
these were the days before mickey mouse
owned
literally everything but as you can
imagine two studios fighting over a
movie's direction
is laden with issues but this wasn't any
old movie this was a james cameron movie
a director famous for his tyrannical
approach to directing
his staff actually wear t-shirts that
read you can't scare me i work for james
cameron that's no lie
after five days of what i can only
imagine was an ocean of suits running
backwards and forwards
a deal between the two studios was
signed at 2am
and the movie shoot was about to begin
little did they know
how many problems would soon follow the
film was almost
immediately under-budgeted and studio
executives began to get the sense that
this giant epic about a sinking ship
was about to sink under its own
financial burden
their first clue probably should have
been the fact that rather than build a
normal movie set
james cameron decided to build a
gigantic water tank that contained
an almost life-size replica of the
actual ship
that's not a joke he wanted a near
full-scale
rms titanic 90 the size of the original
with a poop deck that could rotate 90
degrees into the air
identical to how the ship looked as it
sank
and he wanted that in a 7 million gallon
open air tank the largest ever built
naturally he went about this by using 10
000 tons of explosives
to blow a crater in mexico for his tank
then hired over 1
500 construction workers to build his
ship
and i mean why not who needs cgi when
you have 10 000 tons of ammonium nitrate
and a sociopathic director whilst all
this was going
on the studios began to suspect that the
budget issues were in fact a con
job instigated by the other studio and
more suits began to scurry back and
forth
argue and cause problems until a new
deal was formed
not that cameron cared he was busy
making his movie
and it turns out building the ship
wasn't enough
he wanted everything replicated and i
mean
everything plates knives even the exact
wallpaper
used on the real ship he even demanded
that he get a special russian submarine
to explore the wreck of the actual rms
titanic
not the one he built the one at the very
bottom of the atlantic ocean
and once filming began so did a raft of
new issues
filming in the water left countless crew
members coming down with coals
flu and even kidney infections the stars
feared they were drowning
kate winslet chipped her elbow insanely
a disgruntled crew member spiked the
crew's soup with pcp
one of the most dangerous drugs in the
world
50 people were hospitalized including
actor bill paxton
people were rolling around on the floor
hallucinating and james cameron managed
to vomit before the drug took hold of
him
the person responsible was never caught
but i'm guessing it was bill ponderosa
one reason for the spiking may have been
that cameron was so tyrannical in his
approach and would flip into a rage so
quickly
that crew members felt he had a split
personality
filming costs soon ballooned to 200
million dollars
and shooting took 160 days instead of
138.
an executive came down to try and tame
cameron only to get trapped in a trailer
with him whilst he flew off the handle
saying they'd have to kill him before
they could fire him
industry trades in the newspapers widely
reported the film as an
oncoming flop and nobody not even
cameron had any idea
how the film would do financially the
film was delayed
there were arguments over when it should
be released and marketed
a confrontation that almost culminated
in a fist fight
when cameron finally turned in the film
the studios were horrified to find
it was three hours long fearing that
nobody would sit for a three-hour love
story blockbuster
and they'd lose more money on an already
bad investment
cameron naturally refused and one can
only assume
he flew into another rage but privately
he felt he'd never be allowed to work in
the industry again
he even offered to forfeit any money he
was set to earn from the film
in compensation but then
the film was released it rapidly became
the most successful movie
of all time a title held until recently
it stayed at number one for 16 weeks
straight
a feat never accomplished before or
since
and it won 11 oscars including best
pitcher and director
go figure movies aren't easy to make
they require an enormous effort to
shepherd thousands of moving parts
and countless clashing egos despite this
there are some movies whose production
troubles are so rich with herculean
difficulties
that they have become the stuff of
legend the original dr doolittle for
instance built an enormous artificial
dam
that annoyed the residents of castle
combs so much
that explorer ranul fines came and blew
it up with plastic explosives
jaws was such a troubled production and
it started without a script
a cast or even a shark and led steven
spielberg to think his career was over
and richard dreyfuss was convinced it
was going to be a disaster
harrison ford on the set of star wars
famously told george lucas
george you can type this [ __ ] but you
can't say it it's a shame he didn't say
the same to jj abrams
wesley snipes was so difficult on the
set of blade free that he refused to
communicate by anything except post-it
notes
always signed from blade the production
of the exorcist was infamously
cursed and director william friedkin
slapped an actor
and shot a gun to startle another just
to get the reactions he desired
and heaven's gate was such a disaster
that one reviewer wrote of the director
it failed so completely that you might
suspect mr camino sold his soul to
obtain the success of the deer hunter
and the devil has just come around to
collect
which may just be the most damning movie
review of all time
but what are the most shocking
mind-boggling movie productions ever
what are the movies that were so close
to collapsing under their own weight
that they should probably have never
been made and why does the legendary
actor marlon brando appear in two of
them
george miller's madden max might have
spawned just as many rip-offs as star
wars
it effectively set the tone for
post-apocalyptic action
in countless mediums be it comics movies
video games and even novels
however none of these ripoffs were quite
like
water world which had the genius idea of
taking mad max
and setting it in the middle of the
ocean post-apocalyptic action set on a
future earth where everything is in the
water
sounds pretty awesome right well it's a
shame then that the production was the
movie equivalent of downing a gallon of
coke with a packet of mentos
back in the 90s using computer graphics
to create a city
on water wasn't easy or particularly
convincing
so the filmmakers behind waterwall
decided to take their picture
at face value and film it off the coast
of hawaii
in the middle of the actual ocean
logistically
this was madness burning through 100
million dollars making sets at sea
and with every shooting day depending on
hundreds of people
being ferry to and from the atoll across
the open ocean
and then back again every day for lunch
and when one of your movie's biggest
problems is how the crew
arrive at your set you know you're in
deep
water but the trouble persisted from
there
in the sense that almost everyone kept
nearly dying and everything that
could have gone wrong did kevin costner
almost died when he got caught in a
squall
gene triplehorn and tina mourinho were
thrown from a boat and almost drowned
needing a team of 12 divers to rescue
them there were countless jellyfish
stings
two stuntmen were injured and one went
missing in the middle of the ocean
found deep in the channel moments away
from being swept out to sea
to top it off a hurricane struck and
sank one of their million dollar sets
screenwriter joss whedon was flown out
to save the script
which had proven to be a mess an
experience he described as
seven weeks of hell where everyone
ignored what made the idea work
mutant people at sea and instead turned
it into a generic action movie where he
was forced to edit in star kevin
costner's ideas
with little input of his own eventually
filming was finished having run up an
enormous budget of 175 million dollars
and the director walking away from the
picture entirely
the original score which was completed
for nearly 25
of the film was reportedly rejected as
to
ethnic and after getting savaged as much
as
possible by critics it took the film
until its blu-ray release
nearly 15 years later to earn its money
back
i still think it's a damn cool idea for
a movie though
now you know your film production has
lost its mind when you shot over 1.5
million feet of film but with apocalypse
now
that's precisely what happened
apocalypse now
if you haven't seen it is a fantastic
vietnam war retelling of joseph conrad's
heart of darkness
the film tells the story of a special
forces soldier set to hunt down a
colonel
who has lost his mind deep in the
vietnamese jungle
amidst the heat and bloodshed of the
vietnam war
it's not surprising then that everyone
making the movie seemed to lose their
minds as well
aside from a typhoon wrecking the sets
or the u.s government denying the film
any support
or the director francis ford coppola
blowing his budget
and having to fund the film himself
apocalypse now took an incredible toll
on the people making it with the actors
descending
seemingly against their will into a
world of madness
martin sheen suffered a heart attack in
the middle of filming
and was struggling with alcoholism so
badly that there are literally scenes in
the finished film where he's completely
inebriated
dennis hopper whose character was off
his face was supplied drugs by the
production
so that he could maintain his
performance and harrison ford was so
nervous he could barely perform his only
scene
but it was the great actor marlon brando
who was truly the strangest he showed up
enormously overweight maybe 300 pounds
to the point where whatever scene he was
in
he filled the entire frame and had to be
shot in darkness
he hadn't learned his lines nor even
read the source material
causing the entire production to be shut
down for a week
whilst coppola was forced to read brando
the script
eventually brando showed up with a
shaved head
and just started improvising coppola
himself was so
stressed by the production and blaming
himself for sheen's heart attack
suffered an epileptic seizure a nervous
breakdown
and is said to have threatened suicide
no less than three times
the film shoot was us a chaos constantly
being rewritten on the fly
with the crew either being fired or
plagued by tropical diseases
and the various military equipment
loaned by the local government
was constantly being requisitioned to be
used in the fight against rebels but
perhaps
the strangest story were the rumors that
real dead bodies were being used on the
set
although dismissed at first real
cadavers were
eventually discovered with their use
being justified
as authentic it turns out they got them
from
a doctor he was actually a grave robber
when the police showed up and saw all
the unidentified bodies
it was naturally a fairly incriminating
scene
and everyone's passport was seized yet
luckily
a few days later the grave robber was
caught and sent to prison
interestingly if you ever watched the
film and wonder how they made the
buffalo killing scene look
so authentic you might be interested to
know that they didn't actually do
anything special
they just took a real buffalo and filmed
a local tribe
cussing its head clean off so that just
about sums up the entire movie
but apocalypse now wasn't the most
troubled movie shoot in history
nor was it the most troubled model in
brando shoes in history
no that title goes to a far more bizarre
picture
i'm of course speaking of the island of
dr moreau
the island of dr morrow was a 90s
retelling of h.g
wells novel of the same name a story
about a mad scientist
who fuses animals and men into strange
hybrids
but the movie adaptation well it gives
crazy
a new definition the film was a dream
project of director richard stanley who
landed the job after coercing marlon
brando to play the eponymous dr moreau
but his methods for doing this were less
than conventional
he contacted a warlock that's not a joke
stanley had a ritual undertaken that
would supernaturally bind stanley
and brando to the project and as
fate would have it the spell proved to
be a success
at least as far as getting brando on
board who demanded that stanley be the
one to direct the picture
but it perhaps had further consequences
neither stanley nor his warlock
intended strange events began to mount
up
the warlock became hospitalized with
bone disease
and a flesh-eating parasite stanley's
mother's house was struck by lightning
three times
and there were multiple reports from
neighbours that a ghostly
supernatural hyena was stalking the
nearby hills
i guess that's what happens when you use
witchcraft to get your movie greenlit
but these were just the first of the
issues
actors were hired and replaced at great
speed with both
bruce willis and james woods entering
and leaving the picture
val kilmer who had been hired in a lead
role discovered his wife was divorcing
him
and struggled to cope and marlon brando
suffered a family tragedy when his
daughter committed suicide
and he became a recluse when filming
began both actors were incredibly
difficult and
bizarre to work with kilmer wanted his
role to be as small as possible
and when brando arrived he brought with
him several strange requests
his character would wear white face
paint
he would have an ice bucket for a hat
and he would
again this is not a joke have an
identically dressed [ __ ]
he would follow him around and play the
piano with him
yes this was the inspiration for mini-me
astonishingly all of this made its way
into the movie
sadly his suggestion that moreau be
revealed to be a dolphin in disguise
was not included in a feat of staggering
laziness brando refused to learn his
lines and instead asked for them to be
delivered through an earpiece
however when the earpiece started
picking up transmissions from a nearby
police scanner
brando in full character as monroe began
to declare that there had been
a robbery at woolworths when
tensions or rather egos rose between
brando and kilmer both actors will get
caught in a standoff where
neither was willing to leave their
makeup trailer before the other
tensions arose between the director and
studio so much
that stanley was booted off the set and
replaced with veteran director john
frankenheimer
stanley was escorted to the airport by
security staff
but when his plane landed in lax he
wasn't
on board a while later he was found
and this is true living in the jungle
subsisting on fruit and nuts
he eventually sneaked back onto the set
disguised as one of the animal human
hybrids
and started to attack the sets with an
axe
amazingly he managed to sneak into the
wrap party
where he got to tell val kilmer what a
[ __ ] he thought he was
john frankenheimer had no easy time
himself he was forced to grapple with
kilmer and brando so much
that some scenes had to be filmed by the
animal behavior specialist
but the specialist just completely as a
baboon was unintelligible behind his
costume
and left the crew puzzled as he
attempted to direct them in what sounded
like
random screeches and grunts
frankenheimer grew to despise kilmer so
much
that when kilmer finished his last scene
the director had security force him
off set and shockingly the world's
smallest man who played the smaller
moreau clone
was said to have gone mad with power and
sexually propositioned every woman on
set
and he did this through the use of an
interpreter
his sister so in short
it was complete and utter madness
a fundamentally broken film with a
fundamentally broken script
a fundamentally broken shoot and a
fundamentally
insane crew who were all so bored with
the delayed production
that they gorged on drugs alcohol and
sex-filled orgies to pass the time
thanks for watching you can now
pre-order my brand's new book stick a
flag in it
on amazon link in the description thank
you